welcome back y'all our next guest is a
super talented singer songwriter whose
latest album is an Ode to these Autumn
months when the leaves are turning and
changes in the air especially in his
hometown in New England that album is
called stick season and it's out now
joining us amid his sold out Nationwide
tour performing Northern attitude give
it up for Noah Khan
[Applause]
foreign
breathing out
how you been
settled down
feeling right
feeling proud
how your kids where are they now
you build a boat
build a life
you lose your friends you lose your wife
settle in
True Team
where are you
what does it mean
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
if I get too close
[Music]
the sun don't rise
till the summer time
[Music]
little light
[Music]
he bought some
researched online
lost
getting high
all alone
later life
scared to live
scared to die
you build a boat
you build a life
you lose your kids you lose your life
you settle down
feeling lost
you're getting stoned
thank you getting rocks
[Music]
[Music]
get too close
[Music]
[ __ ] it too close
and I'm not how you hoped
forgive my Northern attitude
[Music]
all right one more time for Noah Khan
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]